today is the first time I'm sharing one
of the toughest situations that I ever
faced during my time in Consulting and I
hope that this situation is Rich of
lessons for you on what you can do to
avoid these things in the future these
principles all tie together into
arguably the most important mindset that
you need to adopt if you want to succeed
in any corporate or industry role and
this is that perception is reality so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel from learning my name is hich
I'm a former McKenzie consultant and on
this channel I want to help you to
succeed in the first years of your
career the situation I will not talk
about happened about one year into my
Consulting career I was a young
consultant I was about 24 years old and
I got staffed on a new project it was a
rather big team Project Lead With I
believe four additional Consultants that
this project team was managing the
project was already going on for quite
some time and in the first week I got
the this feeling that many clients in
the organization especially in the
division that I was supposed to cover
that these clients were rather hostile
towards us as a consulting firm by
extension also towards me and with one
year of ten year you are expected to
already be somewhat independent to
independently lead certain work packages
of the project to independently develop
ideas structure parts of the projects
together with your client counterparts
this was exactly the situation that I
was in and in the very first weeks of
this project different things went South
and let me just share a few of these
instances to give you a better feel of
what was going on so with one of the
work Parts I was supposed to lead I
suggested to do a kickoff meeting
together with the client counterpart the
project lead on the client side who was
leading this so I helped this client to
put together some project management
around the initiatives that we wanted to
drive help the client to put together a
document for this kickoff meeting put
together some content based on some
research to present this then to the
team but quickly I got the impression
that the client was not too eager to
work with me he was rather defensive and
gave me the impression that he wanted to
do all of this rather alone without my
help then the kickoff meeting happened
there was the client Project Lead about
eight nine other clients in the room and
me as well unfortunately I was alone no
one else from my team was able to join
this very meeting again I was a young
consultant and then what happened is
that during this meeting the client
Project Lead was leading it I was rather
quiet didn't contribute too much in the
meeting also because it wasn't a topic
that was already very familiar with
beyond what I already contributed in the
initial preparation of the document and
what then happened afterwards was that
the client Project Lead complained about
me to my team to my internal Consulting
Project Lead and also to the partner who
was responsible for this engagement
saying that I'm not adding enough value
that my contributions were not helpful
that I didn't do much to prepare all of
this and to guide this in the right
direction first situation second
situation that I faced in these very
same weeks early in the project there
was a second work stream a second work
package that I was supposed to lead as a
young consultant and this was supposed
to happen in collaboration with another
client another client Project Lead but
the problem was that this client was not
located close to us but rather somewhere
else the client actually lived on
another continent and there was a time
far before Co so video calls weren't
really a thing it all happened via
telephone conferences so we Tred to
schedule some meetings with this person
this person cancelled meetings was on
vacation was Ill we did manage to talk
to this person a few times but here
similar situation the person didn't seem
to be too eager to talk to us to set
something up with us to get going on
this initiative and then after a few
weeks what happened where we didn't
really get far with this client to kick
this Initiative off that we hope to work
on together with this client and then
the business unit head of this division
that I was supposed to cover as
associate got kind of unhappy right
didn't see the progress didn't really
understand why that was the case what
was going on the framing wasn't really
clear right the client Project Lead who
pushed us back was kind of politically
smart putting the blame on us or
specifically on me that I didn't already
Advance the whole initiative enough that
I didn't already prepare all types of
things of course from my perspective
that was very difficult without the
collaboration with this very person and
this was then the second instance where
a client complained about me towards the
Project Lead towards the partner next
instance happening in the very same few
first weeks of that project we are
planning to do a few analyses on this
business unit and I was meeting one of
the finance leads of this business unit
to collect some data that we needed for
these analyses so this is really
standard procedure this is more or less
what happens on every single project you
have some plans some things you want to
do you need data for it so you meet with
some controlling some Finance people in
the organization to collect what you
need and I went there actually well
prepared I'd say probably better
prepared than for many other of these
meetings that I had in the past had an
agenda I had a formal data request I was
sitting together with this Finance
person in the office discussing all the
points and here again similar situation
I sense from the start this person did
not want to help me this person no
interest at all in providing me with any
information about the business and so I
waited after a few days or a week
nothing came the person sent me a few
bits and pieces but not really what I
was looking for and then actually I
heard that this person again complained
about me internally in the organization
saying that I was asking random
questions I came completely unprepared
to the meeting which now even with some
distance some time distance in between
that was just completely wrong some type
of political game that made me or our
consulting company look bad and again
same picture complaints to the project
lead to my internal Consulting Project
Lead complaints to our Consulting
partner and I was always the culprit of
all of this at least this was the
framing that all these people adopted
now what added to all of this was that
on other parts of the project there were
some issues as well the Project Lead was
quite under pressure as well because
there were some other fires that the
person tried to put out parallel and
this led to me being very independent in
all of these things I was alone in most
meetings with all of these clients so
there also wasn't another pair of eyes
who could have supported me also in the
internal discussions that followed after
all of this now all of this happened 10
years ago and I can look at it with some
distance but in the very situation this
felt crushing I was under huge also
psychological pressure I couldn't really
sleep I remember how depressed I was on
the weekends at home that on Monday
morning I needed to board the plane
again fly to the client location again
and to expose myself to the whole
situation over and over again week after
week and what was so tough is that you
not only got this pressure from the
clients which is probably rather common
situation that you have in Consulting
but that I got this pressure also from
the team so over time I really got
elated from the team the Project Lead
was not really happy with me also that
person try to kind of put the blame on
me right which is surely also not good
leadership on the project lead side the
partner was very unhappy with me I felt
how at least in my perception than often
and increasingly got unfairly treated in
team meetings where I presented
something and at least to me at often F
like people were just trying to look for
things that I did wrong just to frame me
more in the direction of me not
delivering not doing my job well to make
this consistent with everything that the
clients were saying in the first first
weeks of this very project so let's now
talk about the lessons what did I learn
from all of this and frankly did take me
some time to really process it to really
understand the lessons that all of this
had for me and I hope that these lessons
are helpful for you as well in your
careers if you are facing similar
situations like this as well and it
indeed comes all down to the principle
perception is reality perception is
reality and what this means is that in
the end of the day how you see the word
your reality is more or less irrelevant
of course I can complain all time how it
was not my fault that I wasn't really
able to participate in this kickoff
meeting the Project Lead didn't want my
help right the Project Lead didn't even
let me contribute to it of course I can
complain about how it wasn't my fault
that I wasn't able to kick off this
second initiative second work stream
with this client that is living on
another continent because the client
just was not accessible to me at all of
of course I can't complain about that it
wasn't my fault with the finance
professional that this didn't work out I
was prepared I presented a clear data
request but in the end of the day what
sticked is that the clients and also my
team got the perception that I wasn't
doing my job well probably on the client
side this was more some type of
political game that they were playing
but especially then internally in my
consulting firm this was the perception
that was created in the team and of
course this was was not helpful for me
for my career for my performance
evaluation of the project thankfully the
next project I got stared on went really
well for me so it didn't really hurt my
career in the long term but surely I
would have hoped for a different outcome
and if alone for the pressure and my own
very personal psychological Health now
before we jump into the specific lessons
of this project that I just described to
you let's acknowledge that there's one
more generic thing that you always need
to look out for and this is that you
need to make sure that the documents
that you create are always top-notch are
clean are on point because if you make
errors here this is something where than
other people can go after you can attack
you and this is why I prepared for you a
free download of a document checklist a
checklist that I created during my time
in Consulting to help me to make sure
that the written documents I create meet
highest Professional Standards you will
find a link to this free checklist in
the video description for free to check
that one out trust this will be very
helpful to you now let's talk about the
specific project I just described to you
and there are four main lessons I want
to share with you the first lesson is
that you need to always put yourself
into the driver seat of the work that
you're leading you cannot let it happen
that you suddenly become reactive and
let other people dictate the pace or the
things that are happening in your area
of responsibility and here specifically
for this kickoff meeting I try to
prepare together with this client
Project Lead I more or less accepted
everything that this person told me this
person didn't want my help okay then
we're not doing this right this person
didn't want this section that I prepared
in the document okay then this is not
happening this person didn't want me to
give me a role in this meeting okay then
I won't have a role I will just sit
there and probably won't contribute much
so this is a misguided mindset even if
you're working in Professional Services
this is not how you should behave for
the very reason that this can lead to
bad situations exactly the type of
situation I found myself in and actually
remember that I talked to another more
experienced associate on the team before
this meeting and I described to the
person situation what was going on that
I didn't really have a role in this
meeting and that associate even warned
me right H be careful here this doesn't
sound right think about how you want to
approach this but I just brushed it off
didn't really understood what this
person meant until then later I very
much understood what this person was
talking about so what could I have done
well I could have insisted on having a
role in the meeting I could have
insisted on managing a certain part of
it presenting maybe a certain part of it
and then if that person really
absolutely refused to have me at any
part of it at all I could potentially
have refused to sit in this meeting to
participate in preparing this meeting
because apparently there was no help
needed or no help wanted and then maybe
the situation would have escalated a bit
but then at least I would have been able
to point towards that person not letting
me be part of the project and not
accepting the help and then the
discussion would have been a different
one compared to me just being reactive
and just waiting for the criticism of
what was coming out of this put yourself
into the driver seat of your work if you
can see that a certain meeting is not
setting you up for Success that
something is going wrong then cancel the
meeting or reschedule it if you're
seeing that something is not set up the
right way then change it don't just go
with the flow and React to what other
people are doing be proactive you are
the one who should set the agenda who
should set the pace at least for the
part of the work that you are
responsible for second lesson change the
focus of the project actually what
happened is that after a few months into
this project the Project Lead internally
on our side the Consulting Project Lead
changed and a new project lead was
stepping in and then confronted with all
this mess what this project lead
actually did is within one or two weeks
the Project Lead cancelled several of
the initiatives we were working on the
project lead just went to the client and
said hey you know this is not working
out we don't feel like we can really
have the impact we want to have due to
all these reasons and then the project
he had a few suggestions what to do
instead what other initiatives might be
where we would be more set up for
success and I was very scared of this I
was very Unsure how this would play out
but then the client just said yeah sure
let's do it let's do exactly this this
is a great idea and then from one day to
the other everything was different right
we worked on new topics with other
client counterparts the relationships
improved substantially from there
everything was much better just due to
this change and actually this is a
pattern that I observed over and over
again also with working with other
project leads on future projects and
this is that the very good project leads
they didn't even let it come that far
right they didn't even let it come that
far that they would find themselves or
the team in a dead end where they are
not set up for Success where they're
just doomed to fail good project leads
anticipate this that maybe a certain
Road or certain initiatives or certain
parts of the projects that it's
impossible to make them successful then
are able to align with all the relevant
stakeholders that the focus maybe shifts
so something different to another
initiative another topic where then the
chances of success are much more
pronounced next important lesson is that
you always create clear paper trades of
what is going on in your project so
whenever you're faced with a sensitive
situation maybe a difficult person that
you're interacting with or just in
General if in doubt because you never
know what will happen in the future make
sure that all important decisions all
important things that you did are well
documented that there is something in
writing to prove what actually happened
what you actually did and here at the
example of this client meeting with the
finance professional yes I did prepare
an agenda yes I did prepare a clear and
concise data request but what I didn't
do is that I didn't never send this
agenda or this data request to the
client in writing for instance per email
if I would have been able to prove that
it's not correct that I was unprepared
it's not correct that I was just asking
random questions but there was a clear
data request behind all of this and so
on probably this would at least helped
me in all the discussions and all the
outfall that was coming from this very
instance every decision that you take
every important meeting every document
that you create make sure to document it
indeed create a paper trail that you can
point to in case of Crisis next lesson
is to make sure to escalate situations
at the right time and this is always a
thin line because of course you don't
want to be too confrontational you don't
want to make other colleagues or clients
look bad in front of their leadership so
often you tend towards playing it nice
you tend towards trying to just figure
something out with people on a
relationship level but the issue here is
that usually the person or the side that
escalates something first that complains
about something first has the initiative
and has therefore an advantage because
if someone complains about you but
during all the time that passed the last
days the last weeks you never said
anything to anyone about what was going
wrong then suddenly you will sound very
defensive if then confronted with these
complaints then you are starting to
point fingers no it's not you it's about
them and so on so think very hard and
smart about when is the right time to
escalate I know this is easier said than
done but definitely try to avoid finding
yourself in situations where you are put
against the wall where you are in the
defense and someone else has the
initiative on you because the results
however this was caused are not the way
they're supposed to be like now to
maintain confidentiality I did change a
few Minor Details in the story but
overall this is exactly what happened
this was the situation I was faced with
and I hope these lessons are helpful for
you as well because I do think that
situations like this can happen over and
over again not only if you work in
Consulting but also if you work in every
other industry role out there if you
have any other tips on situations like
this I would love to read your comments
or your thoughts on the situations that
I describe to you in the comment section
trust we all can only benefit from that
if there's any value you took away from
this video please destroy the like
button and subscribe to stay up to date
on all my content big thanks to all the
members of the channel for supporting in
me here my name is hinich I'm the
creator of from learning make sure to
grab this free document checklist Link
in the video description see you again
soon all the best to you and bye